[Musique]
notre invité d'honneur raspoutine
je cherche quelqu'un qui pourrait
obtenir une audience avec le tsar
peut-être pourriez-vous me l'étais
je prends des décisions comme on estime
en est plein ou comme et qu ils sont
vides et bien tué merci le dîner sera
bientôt servi
de petits détails peuvent tenir
d'énormes problèmes
nous sommes la première agence de
renseignement indépendance pendant que
les gouvernements attendent des ordres
nous passons à l'action
bienvenue clair il va vous falloir un
costume
c'est très malin on va danser
on arrête de tourner autour du pot
[Applaudissements]
ce duel de gentleman finit pas de
chercher l'idée de te crever me met
l'eau à la bouche
[Musique]
on va voir ça